I used to want to save the world this  beautiful place but the closer you get  the more you see the great darkness  within  I learned this the hard way  a long long time ago  what is your mission to stop the war  what war the war to end all wars weapons  far deadlier than you can ever imagine  the wall can be ours  wherever you are you are in more danger  than you think cannot stand by while  innocent lives are lost  be careful Diana  who is this woman she's my secretary sir  she's a very good secretary  it is our sacred duty to defend the  world and it's what I'm going to do  how could a woman possibly fight in this  fight we use our principles although I  am not opposed to engaging in a bitter  fisticuffs should the occasion arise  you